eight seasons in the NFL won two
championships with the Ravens and the
Eagles and he spent last year with the
Carolina Panthers he's Torrey Smith how
are you Torre I'm good let's start with
your decision to retire where did where
did that come come about how's that come
about for you for me you know it's I've
had a tough year in terms of an injury
as the last year versus Philadelphia
fell down courts and cartilage of and I
ended up having surgery and everything
seemed like it was going to be fine and
there's a rough period and all season
where you know when they told me to rest
where my knee just wasn't getting any
better and somehow some way I ended up
getting a therapy a treatment before
going into camp and I was able to run I
was able to compete and you know I was
then they're back to normal by the end
of camp and then I ended up getting
released and I wasn't starting anymore
and they won the for faith especially
guy and from there you know kind of a
decision to make whether you go to
another chance move the family and you
know and and you know get ready to play
again which I've worked extremely hard
to get to that point or you just call it
a career because I was okay literally
three months before that not thinking I
was going to be able to play so for me
it was like man I had my health you know
the no okay place especially where it
was a few months before then so I was
like it's time just to transition my son
to kindergarten and I said dealing with
that injury and me literally that's all
Susan I was walking around and I was
struggling to get my daughter out of her
crib and walking up the steps and you
know in all kinds of different things
that kind of like a flash of what it
could be down the line for me I was like
man it's not not worth risking there's
gonna take a lot to get me out the couch
and I decided that the time was right to
move on yeah I know and we just saw some
photographs taken from your social media
of your beautiful family so you
obviously are very wealthy on that front
as well so when when it all comes down
to it did you understand when say Andrew
Luck stepped away and it's like I just
didn't
he promised himself he wasn't gonna go
through rehab in the same way that he
did the previous time and how difficult
mentally it is to go through all that
did you feel some sort of I guess
kinship and hearing all that Tory I
think any athlete that ever had an
injury or any person has ever had to
rehab I guess is a little bit different
when you're in a sport because you have
to you have the reality of like will I
be myself again in terms of performing
at a high level and for me I definitely
understood it you know there's a lot of
things that guys have to do just to make
it to Sunday you know everyone's hurting
no one feels good is week two and
there's not a single person that feels
great and it's all about making it to
Sunday and that commitment you know when
you're down you feel you're not even a
part of the team at times and you know
you feel good one day in rehab and then
next thing you know you take four or
five stars biking like man what happened
buddy
confusing so I understood exactly where
he was and our respective decision and I
hope a lot of guys understand that and
now that you learn from that you run
away while you can but you know you need
to understand that life is bigger than
the game so don't sacrifice and show
yourself now if if that's your situation
and you have guys like I've been for the
most part healthy my career and then I
had one routine fall and it changed
everything you know if I wasn't if that
didn't happen in Philadelphia like I
said a routine fall on the sideline
nothing serious had that not happened
then I would have been playing easily
you know whether it's in Carolina or
anywhere else without hesitation but you
know when you have that it makes you
think a little bit more Torrey Smith
here on the Rich Eisen show walk me
through your decision to retire though
in the manner in which you retired with
the deer football letter LeBron and math
Carter's platform on interrupted yes
originally I was going to you know do
like most people especially this time of
year just post an Instagram post and I
was sitting there and I was talking with
my wife and the folks that had
uninterrupted and you know Kay dad and a
platform with a base because it's a
Sincerely Yours where you have that
which I need to express you so
kind of young words so my wife was like
hey why don't you just write a letter I
was gonna do more so a thank you note
and seal it well why don't you just
write it like to the game then it can be
a little bit deeper a little more
meaningful so you know what to work in
there's thought of all the different
things that the game will football is
provided for me beyond just playing and
having a good time and beyond just
finance you know it's a lot of deeper
things that they go into it and a lot of
life lessons that you know I've learned
from the game over the years so you're
not a close personal friend of LeBrons
that were saying to her I mean nah I
never I never met LeBron before you know
he's gonna be one of my favorite
athletes though I have a wall of fame
and in my weight room in my house
there's gonna be done here soon okay
but it's pictures up in there you know I
have I men that I look up to and then
men that I want my kids to respect and
know that they do things the right way
and beyond the suit absolutely go out of
court yeah I know that said I mean you
provided him with quite high quality
content Tory at the very least we should
get a meeting between you and LeBron
down pat certainly with you I just did
how about that I just did Torrey Smith
here on the Rich Eisen show
all right let's I want to hit you with a
couple of topics going on in the NFL one
that's red hot right now is what Paul
Finebaum of ESPN had to say about Cam
Newton and that he doesn't care about
other people was essentially the way he
said that that Cam Newton is now not
himself anymore injury-wise I'm
wondering what your your thought is
having played with him Torrey I think
very disrespectful to speak on someone's
character when you don't know them
personally I'll be the first one to tell
you that and I think everyone knows cam
loves himself right and that's not
necessarily a bad thing like that's who
he is he's confident he loves himself
but I'd be the first one to tell you
that he loves his teammates and he loves
his family and he's a he's a great man
when you get along well I've seen him do
some things for so many different kids
there's so many different people and go
out of his
way and do things and I only want to
tell you some story because I don't even
I don't know what he would want people
to know because he does things that
people flat-out you know you don't see
and honestly you wouldn't expect it I
don't leave me even told me that one
times I see you told me you thought I
was some different type of guy didn't
you and I get was funny we known each
other you know the sense we came in but
you know I being on the same team you
learn a little more about each other
even though we worked on the off season
a few all seasons in the past it was a
little different and the way it was with
everyone from from our homeless man out
there to the next kid or next dismantle
everything you know I've seen them do
some great things and and try to bring
the team together when we talk about a
guy that's a good teammate on the things
they tried to do to keep the the guys
involved keeping anything yes he has his
own way of going about things which
probably isn't very traditional in a
sense but what does that matter I mean
he's been able to perform this because
there's not traditional to the normal
our normal quarterback is supposed to
behave with quotations around that I
mean he does things the right way he's
prepared he knows what to do he works
hard he's gonna push the tempo for
everyone in their room and and try to
raise their expectations for their place
so he's hard on himself than anyone else
which is probably what led to some of
the things that people questioned him
for in the past because yes take so much
riding is working and and those
expectations placed on yourself when you
don't reach that it's very disappointing
so I'm always gonna have his back but I
thought it's very disrespectful to you
know to speak on his character when you
don't know as someone who played with
them and if they tell you that
then you roll with that but don't just
make something up because you had the
ability to watch them fall Torrey Smith
here on the Rich Eisen show and then one
of the teams that you won your
championship with Philadelphia and we
all know the story that year about how
terrific Carson Wentz was and Nick Foles
did his nick foles thing and whence went
out in the season diving headfirst for
an end zone in Los Angeles and hurt his
knee and there he was Torrey
rough he caught the Sunday night game in
Atlanta diving headfirst again and it's
just told
III mean I was stunned
I understand it's tough to change the
way you play do you think whence has has
the I guess the fortitude physically to
survive if he keeps playing in this
manner
Tori yes I mean uh in the NFL I talked
about all the time when they're more
concerned about the way you play it away
mu you can get hurt doing anything like
I just told you I ran I mean II want
routes I've been talking a million and
one times and it was one little routine
fall that I got hurt on and I remember
when Carson got hurt verse the Rams of
him saying Lewis I'm excuse me out in LA
he it was a kind of a food play two guys
hit his leg at the same time and twisted
in that direction and obviously he had
the back issue last year and he's a
quarterback they're going to get hit
there's gonna be times that you can't
that you can't prepare for it so for him
if he sees the opportunity to go get it
and when he's a competitor I can never
see that changing and then you're an
active member of the players Coalition
correct on the board member a task force
so what are your thoughts on jay-z and
and teaming up in the NFL in the manner
in which he did and the conversation
surrounding it your former teammate Eric
Reid has been very vocal on this subject
as well I give you the floor to try and
give me the state of what is going on
from the players coalition yeah well I
think the first thing to acknowledge is
that what the NFL and jay-z did has
absolutely nothing to do with the
players coalition then we weren't aware
we didn't know any of that so and the
player coalition is just a way that the
guys got together to try to figure out a
way to work together to help beyond just
protesting and that's why I was formed
in the guys are able to give grants to
different charities and other folks who
are really doing the work on the ground
doing the real work and while I think
the jay-z and the NFL could possibly do
some positive things down the line
there's a lot of questions and there's a
lot to question about
the way everything initially happened
but one thing I do know is that it's
clearly a business deal in terms of in
regards to music and those things but
when you have someone like jay-z he has
the power to influence and not only has
been you know didn't talk about it but
he's lived it
he's led B he's been able to talk about
these injustice that everyone's
protesting about or talking about he's
lived these things so I don't think you
know can't have a question that piece of
it but obviously it was a business that
I think if it really came out like yes
it's the business there and after that
you know we're gonna try to figure out
ways to work on things but you can't rub
it all into one because it's not the
same thing and I don't view it that way
so I think it's important to acknowledge
that but the matter I'm watching just
like everyone else and I hope that you
know something good comes out of it and
I know
jay-z has at influencing a guy like Nick
mill who when the artist who's going to
be future direct I mean Meek Mill lived
everything everything that people are
protesting about from top to bottom he's
lived at all so the question someone
like meat mill or the question someone
like jay-z it's hard but you know I get
it and it seems very the way things came
about it wasn't the prettiest picture
for anyone to see so what would you like
to see done on the the social justice
front for between players owners in the
league what-what-what maneuver would you
Torrey Smith like to see employed here
for the bowl I wish they employed Colin
Kaepernick you know I think sometimes
just like a black eye to to speak on
issues when a support really changes
when there's a guy out there who has the
ability to play but people don't want to
deal with it the negative press or the
fan reaction that may come from hiring
the player that can help your team in
terms of talent so that would be first
things first but to me I don't view the
NFL as the savior of be this I believe
the NFL has be a building a platform to
educate people the ability and the money
to help those grassroots
to album people directly and ability to
influence others how to do more in their
community I must evaluate I'll see you
there but I think it's always gonna be
hard to talk about the positive things
that the NFL is doing and I'm telling
you listen I'm a guy that if the NFL's
done something positive
I would love to support it because I'm
all for helping other people but I think
no matter how long we go about this it's
always going to be hard to not have some
type of stain when you know a guy like
Colin Kaepernick doesn't even get a
chance to have a workout so where we're
gonna see a next Tory what's what's next
for you in a couple minutes I have left
with you here what do you got for me
heavily involved in the community and
Baltimore I'm looking forward to being a
better family member over the years you
kind of you know the distance and I've
lived in such there pretty far my family
before too you know seeing some of my
younger cousins playing my high school
games you know really getting back home
trying to do that the girls I know my
sons loving the right now I've always
loved to tell but I'm not gonna be
chilling around too long little boy did
this happen you know in the community
and you know maybe joining you in the
media side to talk about some things who
knows
all right Torrey Smith if you ever want
any paparazzi time you know you know you
know how to get in contact with me that
by the way the Rich Eisen show here your
this platform is yours anytime you know
you you know it's very rare to see
somebody like a you know a Terrapin be
able to make it big time and win a
championship in Baltimore and then go to
other places and bring winning there
through your style and and personality
and character I've really enjoyed
watching you and the way you've done it
so you have a platform here anytime
Torrey Smith thank you yeah that means a
lot I appreciate it absolutely
you know Marshall Faulk always told me
not to say congratulations to somebody
who's been retired he said why are you
congratulating me comes I might get a
great career but I saw I'll say to you
congratulations I appreciate I simply
the opposite of that because someone
said I'm sorry for me the other day I
was like
exactly and we all know that NFL stands
for not for long
right and I was able to walk off on my
own I had the option to continue to play
and it was not choice oh don't feel bad
for me I'm just kidding from calling
Beach Virginia
I've been able to accomplish a lot for
your light and make a lot of great
relationships and some memories that'll
last a lifetime so anything I took more
from this game then I would have ever
imagined that I could do for me at
Torrey Smith WR on both Twitter and
Instagram if you want a follow Tory and
his post-playing career world as I will
as well good to chat with you Tory
thanks for calling in thank you yeah you
bet that story Smith right here in the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app